bonjour franck gaudichaud merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
comment est ce que vous expliquez
l'intensité de ces manifestations plus
d'un an après le début du mouvement et à
la veille de ce référendum pour changer
la constitution et bien très
certainement la dynamique du mouvement
populaire se poursuit et d'ailleurs une
levée du confinement donc ça a permis de
nouvelles manifestations
et puis pour les protestataires le
mouvement social l'idée c'est de mettre
la pression sur les autorités sur les
partis alors qu'une partie d'entre elles
et d'entre eux pensent ces manifestants
que le plébiscite et la constitution le
changement de constitution n'est pas la
seule solution en tout cas ne sera pas
suffisant pour répondre à toutes les
demandes notamment les demandes sociales
à un an de cette révolte d'octobre 2010
9 lesquels dit justement ce référendum
qu'est ce que propose la nouvelle
constitution alors c'est vraiment un
jour historique un demain il ya un
plébiscite sur oui ou non changement de
constitution
tous les sondages montrent qu'il y aura
un oui certainement très massif
peut-être plus de 60% et ensuite il ya
une option entre une convention mixte et
une convention constitutionnelle cette
dernière option étant la plus probable
donc ça ouvre le champ à une nouvelle
constitution à une assemblée
constituante mais avec certaines limites
et on était déjà négocié par les parties
et c'est d'ailleurs l'une des critiques
d'une partie des protestataires
c'est à dire dans pour aller plus loin
ça veut dire quoi exactement
si les chiliens vote oui qu'est ce qui
va se passer pour eux alors il faut
souligner un coach il y en a encore la
constitution autoritaire de la dictature
de 1981 donc en ce sens c'est vraiment
un moment attendu par des millions de
personnes en terminer avec les
institutions de pinochet
l'institution néo libérale et
autoritaire si le oui l'emporté la plus
probable on va vers donc un processus
constituant à partir d'avril de 2021 il
y aura donc des élections de députés
constituants si c'est une convention
constitutionnelle est donc là on a
plusieurs mois ensuite vous va si j'ai
cette assemblée et va rédiger une
nouvelle carte au magnat une nouvelle
constitution
donc là l'enjeu est tout de même
considérable en ce sens où c'est
vraiment un
un changement politique qui s'ouvre pour
le syli nouvelle étape dans l'histoire
politique chilienne
justement selon le résultat de ce
référendum si et c'est le oui qui
l'emportent est-ce que la contestation
populaire
peut-elle retombé en intensité ou au
contraire à ce qu'elle peut repartir de
plus belle
alors là évidemment les calculs sont
différents suivant les acteurs pour le
gouvernement et la plupart des partis
politiques
l'idée c'était sous la pression des
mobilisations sociales essayer de
canaliser ses demandes notamment en
n'ouvrant un processus constituant comme
un signe un peu de pacifier les luttes
on peut dire mais de l'autre côté le
mouvement populaire est une par une
toutes une partie des acteurs mobilisés
elle pense qu'il faut continuer la
mobilisation faire pression certains par
exemple le mouvement féministe disent il
faut participer au plébiscite participer
au processus constituant mais aussi le
déborder continuer dans la rue parce que
c'est bien plus qu'une nouvelle
constitution que le mouvement
demande aujourd'hui on se souvient un
mouvement qui a été donc initié il ya un
an se souvient au début de la révolte
ça avait commencé avec l'augmentation du
prix métro quelle est la situation
maintenant d'un point de vue à la fois
économique et d'un point de vue social
au chili en un an qu'est ce qui s'est
passé exactement
bien oui il faut il faut vraiment voir
que la situation est vraiment très très
tendue on est face à une crise
économique et social et le politique
profonde
la pandémie le coronavirus est vraiment
venu impacter très fortement l'économie
chilienne et comme l'économie
latino-américaine et donc ça vient
s'ajouter disons à la crise en pente
depuis plusieurs années aux inégalités
très forte le chili l'un des pays les
plus inégalitaires de la région donc
dans ce contexte de crise sociale et
politique
la crise économique a bien renforcé le
mal être les demandes sociales une
certaine rage aussi au sein des quatre
classes populaires donc très
certainement ce plébiscite ne viendra
pas mettre fin à ce grand site de
mobilisation mais plutôt on rentre dans
une nouvelle à nouveau site où vont se
combiner des mobilisations sociales et
les discussions sur sur la constitution
et et justement si ça perdure malgré le
oui si nous ils venaient à l'emporter
quelle marge de manoeuvre pour le
président conservateur sebastian pinera
qui a été largement contesté depuis un
an mais le l'exécutif actuel est
vraiment très très bas dans les sondages
c'est un des gouvernements les plus
impopulaires de toute l'histoire
républicaine chilienne donc des marges
de manoeuvre très limitée il faut voir
aussi qu'une partie de la droite dure
ouvert de l'extrême droite c'est au sein
de la coalition présidentielle et fait
pression pour plus de répression
renforcer encore un peu plus la
militarisation la présence des
carabiniers donc il ya une tentation ou
ornementales de continuer à répondre
avec une main ferme des répressive et en
même temps des marges de manoeuvre très
limitée puisque il a il se retrouve dans
une situation où peau de son côté ils
appuient le post constitutionnel mais
tout en étant en essayant de le
contrôler et de limiter son impact
donc on peut dire que la crise politique
va continuer et la question réellement
sais quelle alternative démocratique à
cette situation
merci franck gaulin y avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur d'histoire et de civilisation
de l'amérique latine à l'université de
toulouse ii